first make sure you have a full backup
uh yes bartholomew back it up um when
finished reboot the system
john are you getting this yeah yeah yes
this is john mcafee in 1987 he invented
the mcafee antivirus software he had a
net worth of 100 million dollars and
flew to belize to live like a real-life
gta character after a series of events
he was eventually found dead in his
prison cell under mysterious
circumstances he built one of the
biggest antivirus companies to date and
yet it's what happened after this
chapter of his life that made him a
legend
mcafee once lived in belize and got
caught up with drugs and other illegal
activities
he made a bid to run for president
founded his own political party named
the chairman and ceo of a mysterious
company went under investigation and was
eventually found dead in his prison cell
this is the insane story of how a tech
pioneer became a real-life gta character
john mcafee was born in the uk in the
mid-1940s his parents moved to roanoke
virginia when he was young his early
life was tough his father who worked as
a road surveyor was an alcoholic when
mcafee was 15 his father committed
suicide a fact mcafee said he woke up
with every day
mcafee went to roanoke college where he
also took up drinking but the younger
mcafee was a driven entrepreneur at a
young age his first business sold
magazines door-to-door which he said
made him a small fortune he began
working at a company that coded punch
card systems in the late 60s this taught
him the basics of early computing using
this information he landed a job at
missouri pacific railroad where he
helped the company use a newfangled ibm
computer system to help calibrate train
schedules while at missouri pacific
railroad he began to dabble with harder
drugs he would go to work many days
while tripping on lsd one day he was
sold a bag of a psychedelic known as dmt
mcafee snorted a line of the drug felt
nothing and then decided to do the whole
bag and all hell broke loose he freaked
out ran outside and hid behind a trash
can
he never went back to missouri pacific
mcafee moved to silicon valley in the
1970s he held numerous jobs at various
tech companies including a stint at
nasa's institute for space studies all
the while abusing drugs and alcohol he
was working at the company omex and
found his daily routine to be snorting
coke at his desk and drinking a bottle
of scotch
in the 1980s mcafee worked at lockheed
at the time computers were still
relatively new
in 1986 the first computer virus hit pcs
he read about these new programs that
infiltrated computers and decided to
start his own company to fight back
mcafee associates took off by the end of
the 1980s the company was making five
million dollars a year and some of the
biggest companies in the world were
using his antivirus platform
mcafee quickly became even more
successful largely because of a computer
virus called michelangelo that hit the
scene in 1992 mcafee called it one of
the worst viruses to date estimating it
would infect as many as 5 million
computers
at the time computer antivirus platforms
weren't a product most people bought
thanks to michelangelo there was a
growing fever to protect computers from
the virus
though only some tens of thousands of
computers were infected michelangelo
propelled mcafee to go public and it
turned into a multi-million dollar
business
in 1994 mcafee set his sights for
greener pastures and resigned from
mcafee
two years later he sold his shares which
gave him about a hundred million dollars
following his resignation mcafee kept a
relatively low profile he would give
young startups advice lecture at
stanford graduate school of business and
also work on projects of his own in 2008
however the economic collapse caught up
to him one report said that his fortune
had shrunk from 100 million dollars to
as little as four million dollars
in the late 2000s mcafee decided to sell
his land and move to belize
a tropical country along the coast of
central america
mcafee resided in a beachfront mansion
with his girlfriend alison adonizio
she was a botanist who studied the use
of plants in medicine and antibiotics
mcafee had committed to funding her
research in the hopes of developing a
new pharmaceutical drug for their
company quaromax
however quaramax would soon go south as
mcafee's personality took a turn for the
worst in december of that year mcafee
had developed an addictive drug habit
he posted to an online drug forum about
his use of bath salts more specifically
mdpv a psychoactive and synthetic
stimulant that has effects similar to
that of cocaine mcafee posted his
experience and also cited that he was
manufacturing strains of mdpv that he
claimed to have tested on himself
mcafee's drug habits would only further
spiral him into a life of crime and
violence it is believed that mcafee
began distributing illegal drugs he
built up a reputation in belize he
surrounded himself with many street
escorts and local gangsters
mcafee also loved guns and had a hefty
supply at his compound mcafee bragged
about sleeping eating and showering with
a pistol at all times
he was not untouchable and had developed
many enemies along the way in an
interview mcafee stated that enemies in
belize and even his own girls had tried
to kill him more than a dozen times in
order to ensure his security mcafee
created his own law enforcement
consisting of ex-cons local gangsters
and corrupt police officers in the
neighboring village with this strong
network of protection mcafee had
essentially taken the power of the
caribbean town under his own authority
at one point he even set a curfew for
the town to abide by and threatened to
kill anyone who disobeyed the curfew
eddie mccoy also known as mach 10 was a
notorious gangster in belize and was
also one of mcafee's close acquaintances
amongst the gang
at one point mcafee had allegedly hired
maktan as a hitman who was responsible
for the brutal and public execution of
another man accused of robbing one of
their properties although the government
had previously suspicions of mcafee's
activities his involvement with mach 10
is what led to a serious investigation
shortly thereafter the gang suppression
unit also known as gsu would raid
mcafee's compound under the assumption
that he was manufacturing and
distributing metamphetamine he woke up
at six in the morning to 42 armed
soldiers in full riot gear carrying
automatic weapons storming his property
they would discover multiple firearms
and stacks of cash but no illegal
substances to incriminate him
mcafee would post online that he was in
hiding and on the run from the corrupt
gsu law enforcement who had been hunting
him
under extreme paranoia he would recount
the instance in which he was tracked
down on the local beach and held
surrounded by half a dozen large armed
men
after such instances mcafee later moved
back to his beachfront villa away from
his laboratory compound
mcafee had brought back his gangster
lifestyle of guns girls and guards as
you can imagine many of his neighbours
were frightened by mcafee's gang
residents filed a petition against
mcafee stating that his security guards
and dogs created an unsafe environment
for locals and tourists one resident
greg fall was mcafee's most vocal critic
four was a former marine living in his
dream home on the beach of belize for
his retirement however the two had many
run-ins which led to some physical and
almost deadly altercations greg fall had
come across a pack of mcafee's dogs
along the beach and confronted him in
which mcafee threatened fall with a
firearm in later weeks mcafee's dogs
were all found poisoned and killed by an
unknown assailant
allegedly this was fall's own way of
handling mcafee however this has never
been confirmed
a few weeks later greg fall was found
murdered in his home
investigations of the murder reveal a
break and enter in which fall was
tasered multiple times and then shot in
the back of the head
motive and a fit to the crime pointed
right back to mcafee who would become a
person of interest for detectives when
pursued for questioning mcafee went back
into hiding he claimed that the gsu had
actually made an attempt on his life and
mistaken him for his neighbor
other theories on fall's murder point
back to mach 10. according to an
interview with mcafee's custodial worker
he was given five thousand dollars from
mcafee to wire into mac 10's bank
account and had driven him across the
beach the knight of fall's murder
despite all key evidence pointing back
to mcafee belgian officials did not have
dna testing at the time of the case and
could not link anything back to them
still on the run from the police mcafee
was able to dodge authorities by
constantly moving between motels and
changing his appearance however he
eventually had his location exposed on a
vice documentary and was forced to flee
guatemala shortly after mcafee was
arrested outside his hotel for entering
the country illegally the foreign
ministry of guatemala didn't know how to
handle him since they didn't hold any
actual outstanding arrest warrants for
mcafee because there were no reason to
detain him he did not have any legal
case pending against him they decided to
extradite mcafee back to belize but
before he could be extradited mcafee
faked a heart attack he was able to buy
some time for his legal attorney which
further allowed an appeal to go through
in which mcafee was sent back to miami
mcafee and mach 10 were never found
guilty for the murder of greg fall
following this a media frenzy ensued
everyone wanted to know who he was where
he was going and if he was crazy
so he uploaded a video titled how to
uninstall mcafee antivirus it showed him
surrounded by women while trying to
uninstall the software he invented the
video also showed guns and allusions to
drugs and drug use although it was
undoubtedly meant to be some sort of
parody
in august mcafee was arrested on charges
of dui and handgun possession in a
facebook post he admitted to driving
under the influence of xanax but blamed
his doctor for not specifying that
driving while under the influence of the
drug could be dangerous in 2015 he filed
paperwork to run in the 2016
presidential race and announced he would
form his own political party the cyber
party mcafee took his campaign to the
libertarian party national convention
but failed to secure the nomination in
may mcafee was appointed chairman and
ceo of a mysterious tech company mgt
technologies the company originally
invested in daily fantasy and mobile
games but pivoted to cyber security the
company also announced its investment in
a tiny drug maker unrelated to cyber
security in august 2017 mcafee stepped
down as ceo instead serving as mgt's
chief cyber security visionary in
january 2018 he left the company
altogether both sides said the split was
amicable he said he wanted to spend all
of his time on cryptocurrencies while
the company told of pressure from
potential investors to disassociate
itself from him in october 2020 mcafee
was arrested in spain at the request of
the united states department of justice
for tax evasion the u.s securities and
exchange commission filed a complaint
further alleging mcafee and his
bodyguard promoted certain initial coin
offerings in a fraudulent cryptocurrency
pump and dump scheme it claims he
presented himself as an impartial
investor when he promoted the icos
despite allegedly getting paid 23
million dollars in digital assets in
return in march 2021 the us attorney's
office for the southern district of new
york formally indicted him on these
charges
mcafee was jailed in spain pending
extradition to the united states then in
june 2021 mcafee was found dead in his
prison cell in barcelona hours after the
spanish national court ordered his
extradition to the united states on
criminal charges the catalan justice
department said everything indicated he
killed himself by hanging
an official autopsy apparently confirmed
his suicide but mcafee's death ignited
speculation about the possibility that
he was murdered mcafee's death drew
comparisons to the circumstances of the
death of american financier jeffrey
epstein who was found dead in august
2019 while awaiting trial on sex
trafficking charges several times mcafee
claimed if he were ever found dead by
hanging it would mean he was murdered he
even tweeted about it minutes after the
report of his death an image of the
letter q was posted on his instagram
feed his account was subsequently taken
down apparently in reference to cuenon
conspiracy theories the day after his
death his lawyer told reporters that
while he regularly maintained contact
with mcafee in prison there were no
signs of suicidal intent mcafee's widow
reaffirmed this position in her first
public remarks since her husband's death
and also called for a thorough
investigation
there's a lesson in every story what can
we learn about mcafee's insane journey
well you could argue that he stepped
over the line his actions eventually got
the authorities involved and no matter
how powerful he thought he was he
eventually got caught from tech pioneer
to real-life gta character mcafee is
certainly an eccentric entrepreneur he
started a company that revolutionized
the tech industry and cemented his
legacy and name in history he just
wanted to live as a true sovereign
individual a free man who didn't care
what others thought of him it's
debatable whether he actually took his
own life as he died in very mysterious
circumstances
the details of his death are still
shrouded in mystery and nobody knows for
sure but the comment section in this one
will be very interesting thanks for
staying till the end of this video if
you enjoyed this video then be sure to
hit the like button drop a comment
subscribe and hit the notification bell
for more content like this
also be sure to check out our other
videos on this channel links are in the
description and we'll see you in the
next one